you wrote this book little weirds and
just all kinds of those observations I
mean how long do you spend working on
this this is really nice
well I got the book deal I had a year to
do it
which meant like about ten months of
procrastination yes yeah and I think
that's for everybody yeah like they just
announced that President Obama's book he
made this book deal like the minute he
left office yeah and that they just got
moved for like the second time because
clearly he's just chilling yeah he
should he's a human being is chilly and
you know maybe he's just like I don't
know I want to get high I don't want to
yeah where's your book yeah you'll get
your book yeah I mean that that I mean
others I would never dare to compare
myself to Barack Obama but all the time
call me one of our coolest presidents
but I want to get high I want to get my
so uh but so I took I sort of wrote it
by myself on Martha's Vineyard in my
parents empty house and it I really kind
of did it over a couple months right
yeah just like an emotional you know you
you do something right about your dreams
and your dreams are quite strange quite
weird yeah and and in a very specific
way yeah and that they're disappointing
and boring well it's you take it on here
sure so I was having a series of dreams
that were like exceptionally boring in
the book I write about a dream where I'm
waiting in line for a sandwich and
that's it that's it yeah I see what I
love is that so many people think that
their dreams are really interesting and
they never are yeah and you go out of
your way to say no no these dreams are
not interesting and now and there and
then you read them and they really
aren't interesting yeah like it's a new
level you know of not interesting like
what's another one another one is a what
I described to myself I guess as a
tensionless seven our dream during which
an airplane landed
during the day and it ended just fine
yeah and the message of the dream is
nothing cared that nothing cared not
great no not great not great in the
sandwich dream it's like at least I
could get to the end of the line but you
never do no I don't know I don't do you
know what the sandwich is that you want
to get I usually want the same sandwich
yeah but the sandwich in itself isn't
that exciting it's just like Turkey and
mayo and lettuce and hot sauce American
cheese so the sandwich is just a
sandwich yeah yeah the sandwich isn't
like a treasure chest made out of bread
with like my rabbis face coming out of
it being like like that's what it is and
the worst part is that or the nicest
part whatever my fiancee like every
night has these like gorgeous mythical
dreams like what like it's like he's
like I'm like babe what you dream about
he's like well I'm a thousand years in
the past and I'm going down the Nile
River with a young Pharaoh to my left is
a bird singing opera and then I realized
we do have multi lives
why and he's like what about you and
then like I tripped on the peanut dad
Wow
yeah you don't say sounds like he's a
cent or like a magical creature he kind
of is in a way it's sort of a thing
we're like when I met him I was like
don't spook it like don't do anything
right you can like run back into the
enchanted forest right yeah right yeah I
can't wait to meet him yeah sure I'll be
invited to the wedding you just saw a
moment of real awkwardness I'm busy that
day whatever it is anyway so many people
on a yacht know Irish which I would
respect by the way no we have a we have
a clip from your stand-up show stage
fright any setup needed for this or
should we just let it roll oh well okay
I I really love this clip I went to a
midnight Catholic Mass which is not
something I've done before
right yeah I could tell I've done many
many times you have never done yeah and
I was blown away by by how positive it
was and that they were like doing it at
midnight which is like party time
yeah so it's just kind of a joke about
how how exciting in Christianity is kind
of here we go let's take a look at this
clip from stage fright like the
Christmas songs I'm thinking about it
they're all just like jingle jangle
everybody gets the present like Santa
thumbs down but he never catches on fire
we don't know how it happens like
everything's fine we never worry that's
not in our culture like and like the
Jewish songs like the happy songs that
you sing before you open your Barbie van
or whatever you're lucky enough to get I
are the Barbie man
like those songs are just like they try
to kill us in the past do it again
dressed for just a moment there's only
one drop of oil for a million people
[Music]
what's it daddy came here religion as
well very catchy too it's a really
catchy tune here were a bunch of friends
who said that they've started singing it
in the shower tonight when I'm talking
my son in I'm gonna try to kill him
yeah